Je ne peux pas dire assez fermement
que nous assistons au
meurtre au ralenti d'un homme innocent
qui a apporté des
cadeaux
à toutes les personnes
dans le monde qui sont concernées
par les guerres
qui sont concernées par la
dégradation de l'environnement
[Musique]
eh bien
nos attentes sont
sur  la france a manifesté aujourd'hui
il y a 39
députés qui ont formé un
groupe interpartis à l'assemblée nationale
dans le but de
libérer julian et aussi il semble
qu'il soit possible pour julian d'
avoir
la nationalité française et de se voir offrir l'asile
en france ce serait magnifique  donc
nous sommes très sérieux l'us
euh
veut continuer à
torturer psychologiquement julian et le mettre en prison pour
le reste de sa vie
ils le torturent activement en ce moment
dans la prison de belmar ils veulent le mettre
en isolement pour le reste de sa vie
aux états-unis et ils utilisent l'
instrumentalisation de la loi pour
atteindre cet objectif
[musique]
murray
versus vengeance
[musique]
toi